Michelle you were here last year with us
I'm gonna watch a war you're here this
year for the Pennsylvania Court are you
disappointed cats have any support does
not come with cash like last year
healthy enough
oh no it was great big cash flow like
that last year really helped me helps
make up tips I mean he'll be prompt they
helped me live while I was trying to go
over all the production product and you
know helped me go on press tour and
stuff so it was really helpful and it's
always nice so many but in perfect we
have to just the honor this thing's
heavy like Norma
oi
given all of you boys
I'm saying Amy absolutely yeah
I mean we're not going to be at the
Oscars so having a forum you know this
event that is specifically just to
celebrate this particular pan in this
kind of work which is all made
independently encourages you to think
about a camera and go out because it
works without having to wait for you
know installers the studio is really
what has been the most challenging thing
you've had to overcome in your career
what's in this challenging to overcome
in my career I mean that's the biggest
so awesome about this kind of filmmaking
is it's hunting the self-produced and
Senate feature is also self released and
I really have looked at the resources I
had an episode so like you know ask
friends heard of help it's harder to
bake to clean it and I threw together a
movie and now if you can do that
you can actually shoot digitally and you
can you know if you write specifically
to make a movie that's affordable you
can even actually you know I can't I
come out all gun balanced car explosion
so that was kind of a drag but you know
a certain kind of movies on character
based stories can really use it on the
cheap you know and you don't have to
wait for anything to get me permission
to make your work so I can't really
complain about any obstacles especially
if she wins no I really really really
love in but that's mostly because I
think their level is the best-selling mm
really
so yeah I mean I I think it would be
nice for going to get your change what
do you know now that you wish you knew
at the beginning of your career I know
that I wish
we are pleased to have with us on the
line of the film courage studio today
writer director producer actor and
editor Lynn Shelton Lynn's credits
include the just-released award-winning
movie hump day my effortless brilliance
we go way back and many more hello Lynn
welcome such a pleasure for us to have
you here this is wonderful
Lena I wanted to start today's show with
it with a special connection that you
and I share and that is to the deaf
community my mom and dad are both deaf
and one of the things that one of the
first things that you emailed to me was
that was that you have a deaf son you
know and our first correspondents on the
phone just a couple days ago I don't
know you know you told me more details
about what it's like to raise your son
and now and I was curious in terms of
filmmaking how did how do you think you
know having a deaf son and seeing the
world through his eyes how was that
impact impacted your storytelling and
your filmmaking you know I I got you
when you asked me that it got me
thinking about it because I haven't ever
really thought about it before I've
never tried to I mean I know that
someday I would really like to attempt
to make a film specifically for the deaf
community or or for a non hearing
audience you know somebody that
hard-of-hearing audience anyway that is
maybe even more communicates even more
visually than then through sound I'm
really sound is really important to my
films whether it's very music that
driven film like my first feature we go
way back I have tons and tons of music
in it and there's a lot of kind of deep
dependence on the soundtrack and on the
sound design as well or even just
dialogue-driven films like my last two
films there's still the music that does
exist is really important and the the
you know the quality of the sound I just
I really love sound but I you know I
mean Farlow cinema I love both visual
and sound so the visual you know trying
to think about how to tell a story that
might be a particular interest to deaf
folks is something that I know I want to
try to tackle at some point and in terms
of how just how unaffected I mean it's
such a um I don't know it's oh he's my
son Milo is such a huge part of my life
that I think it's just kind of a more of
a sub subterranean you know sort of
under the surface effect that I have on
me as an artist because it's just
affected me as a person he's ten and so
you know the past decade of my life has
been affected by living with somebody
who is hard of hearing in it I but I'm
not very good at I can't I couldn't put
my finger on it I couldn't tell you
exactly what it is I mean it was already
you know I've got a graduate degree in
photography and I've always been really
visually oriented but um well you know
the other thing just occurred to me this
very second is getting into what it's
like to be different you know because
there aren't very many folks in the
world who are deaf and when you're
living in hearing world where the whole
culture is oriented towards you know
towards hearing and listening and
talking and it's uh you know you stand
out you're you're different you have to
you have to really get adapt to that to
being different
so having empathy I think empathy really
has been sharpened in me as a mom over
these last few years for all people who
are different or feel different in some
way and yeah that just I think that's
that's another why probably mm-hmm yeah
and where did you grow up take us back
to the beginning
um I grew up I was born in Ohio
my dad always likes to make sure that I
know I'm a Buckeye very little time in
Ohio and really was raised in Seattle
and ended up getting a theater degree at
the University of Washington and I lived
in New York for about nine years after
in my 20s after I got my degree in the
theater and then I went to school there
for photography got my own essay there
and then moved back to Seattle when I
was pregnant with with my son so I've
been back in Seattle about as long as I
lived in in New York about a decade were
you artistic as a kid oh yeah from a
really early age I guess I was dictating
stories to my mom when I was like four
and I remember writing my first poem and
getting serious about poetry when I was
an age oh yeah keeping a journal you
know when I was like 10 or 11 I think I
started a journal and took my first
acting class when I was 11 and was in my
mom put me in this really great art
program that was very much very
experiential and trying all kinds of you
know I remember making a room sculpture
out of this entire room and just ringing
you know stuff up across the from corner
to ceiling it anyway just really allow
my parents my folks really allowed me to
explore the artistic side of myself and
there was a lot of artistic sides of me
when I was a kid and then I found like I
kind of narrowed it down to really
creative writing into and to acting and
theater in in my college years and it
kind of the writing fell away for a
while and so while I was just acting and
and I moved to New York to do acting was
really excited about it but I just I
started falling out of love at a certain
point with it and that was when I picked
up photography again which was something
I had started when I was in high school
and
and I really sort of transferred my
addiction I mean for me it really felt
like an addiction like I always had to
be in a show you know when I was an
actor and so I just now all the sudden I
was just always in the darkroom and I am
and so yeah it's my artistic expression
has always sort of modes of expression
has that really shifted and morphed 30
years but when I was in the middle of
making my first feature film I was
filming that it's four years ago in 2005
and I I had was struck like a you know
what like a big doll it was so clear
that this is what I you know was always
meant to do was to direct with actors
and make feature films and you know out
of grad school I was I started making in
grad school I was making filming videos
the first time I started in there in the
sort of early mid 90s as a as a solo
artist you know and I was making
completely non-commercial totally just
purely expressive work experimental and
filming video art I was sort of you know
kind of straddling between those two and
my one marketable skill was as an editor
so it was nice was I was making my own
very you know really exploratory
artistic work but I was working on other
people's films learning how to
collaborate with other people and
learning how to tell stories in a very
narrative straightforward narrative way
so especially when I moved back to
Seattle I started getting a lot of work
as a narrative film editor and I edited
two feature films directed by other
people and in several shorts and finally
started feeling you know like this is
something I really needed to tackle to
try doing myself and so finally got
around to that a few years ago that's
made three of them so far and can you
take us into that process Linda of
getting that first feature film started
you know can you go into more details in
terms of how you got that off the ground
yeah well I it's if I'm almost sheepish
to say because I was so incredibly
fortunate I had an opportunity that I
don't know very many other people in the
world who
who have been able to be blessed to have
which is that there was a non-profit
film studio that had just started up in
Seattle and it was started by a really
visionary guy who just had this this
feeling that you know why couldn't you
have a film studio that was kind of
based on the same premise as a Repertory
Theatre Company and instead of putting
on a cycle of five or six plays a year
you could create you know four five or
six feature films a year and they would
be you know existing forever and it
would be fun to chi'lan topically you
know like the Opera like the ballet like
like the theater and so he ran around
and grabbed you know got some big grants
and some big sort of donator donators
donations and then you had this little
pool of people who were functioning as
the keys key collaborators so a
direction photography and key editor and
a production designer or composer
etcetera and then they would go and ask
folks they didn't fight people to write
and direct a feature film and I was one
of those lucky lucky people and I would
have it was perfectly timed for me
because I'd been fantasising it hadn't
really told anybody but I've been
fantasizing about wanting to direct a
feature film that was a narrative film I
think he thought that I was he didn't
know this so he thought I was going to
make an experimental documentary you
know or something along the lines of the
work I'd already been doing and as it
happens I took the opportunity to write
a script I wrote my first script in
about five weeks I had something that
was a very short timeline so the whole
thing was really crazy enough to pre
produce to start casting etc and it was
appurtenant exactly the length of a
gestation period from when he asked me
to when I actually turned the the
project in to submit you know we
submitted to Sundance and Slamdance
it was exactly nine months and it was my
first time on a set because as I said
before I've heard came into narrative
filmmaking through the editing role and
so I've never really been on a working
set before and so it was kind of like
cherry on the top of my you know four
decade-long
film school but this was like my real
intensive film schools of learning about
specific hierarchy and collaborative
nature of a feature film set and the
result was we go way back which
premiered in January of 2006 at
Slamdance and won there a couple prizes
there the best cinematography award and
the best Grand Jury Prize for Best
narrative feature how do you balance all
of this you know moviemaking and being
creative I mean I have trouble sometimes
just taking care of myself to get myself
out the door in the morning you're a mom
and a wife you've attended an MFA
program and photography I mean you've
been an editor and you're writing and
making these amazing films take us
through your day how do you prioritize
what gets done and how do you keep your
sanity while doing it you know I
couldn't I'm everyday really I'm
incredibly incredibly grateful for the
support of my specifically my husband my
son as well they're just they're very
very supportive and they kind of
continue the culture that I felt when I
was growing up with my folks this this
idea I just feel so blessed to be
surrounded by people who believe that
you know we should all do what we love
to do that's you know what we're put
sort of put here on earth to do and be
the best we can be you know and I hope
that I am supporting him in the same way
in that in that emotional you know
psychological way and sometimes it is
hard in a practical way but you know
it's it really has been it's just it's
just kind of it's every day you have to
make a conscious effort to think about
the balance you really do you know so
between work and family between you know
sanity I mean I do get very I have a
tendency to be kind of high strung
I can get really anxious and kind of you
know thanks high-strung as I know that
about myself and so I really try to you
know I don't yet have a completely
perfect regular yoga practice or
meditation practice but I kind of try to
do a little deep breathing whenever I
can when I noticed that I'm getting a
little bit you know too over the top I
must learn to say no to things which was
really difficult for me for a really
long time you know and then I started
realizing wait a minute this is your did
you I can't say yes to everything I just
can't you know and so starting to just
pull back and realizing what your what
the limitations of your time are and if
things get really ultimately things
inevitably rather things do end up
getting really intense but I try to make
sure that if there's an intense two
weeks or three weeks or four weeks of
time that I can schedule things out so
they can be a little there's you know a
little more breathing room over the next
week
you know but yeah it's just kind of a
conscious you know very deliberate and
you know effort to balance you are
listening to film courage in broadcast
live every Sunday 11 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time here in LA talk radio calm
we are on the line with Independent
Spirit Award winner Lynn Shelton and I
found something fascinating Lynn on your
website that relates to your film we go
way back which talks about something you
term the Geisha years in a woman's life
and I believe you say something to the
effect of during a woman's 20s
they almost replicate a Geisha in many
ways sort of trying to please everyone
but themselves I found that very
fascinating because I found that very
true for myself can you tell me how you
came up with this concept
well actually I I can't take credit and
unfortunately I don't know who to give
the credit to I turned on NPR one day
and I was in the middle of us sort of a
lecture a talk by a woman who was in her
50s
who's a writer and I never could find
out who this person was but she was
characterizing different decades in her
life and I was right in the middle of
working on my first film which is really
about that
exact
DRO and she just perfectly articulated
what I have been trying to capture in
that film this sense of you know just
the sort of loss of a sense of self and
really yeah
just kind of trying to please everybody
around being a real people pleaser
especially men you know just really
trying to please man and when I look
back you know it was think I wanted to
make that movie because I was in my late
30s and I was looking back at the
different cells that I had been at
points in my life and and I had this I'm
sure over a Manta sized vision of myself
as a 12 or 13 year old that's just being
so vibrant and kind of clear-eyed no
clarity of vision like really knowing
what I wanted to say and being just
filled with creativity and then at the
end of my adolescence the other end you
know of of you know getting into my
adulthood I I was sort of the opposite I
just I lost all of my agency and my
secret you know
shame was that I could only be an artist
as an actor because I needed I didn't
have any words of my own you know
basically I needed to speak other
people's words and it was the only way
in for me to keep connected to a
creative place but so yeah you know it
was you it was I in her little while ago
that when I was going to know of making
my first feature film I really had the
strong sensation that this is what I was
always meant to do and I and I really
transformed it kind of transformed me as
a person as an artist I just I really
felt like I was coming into my own and
the thing is I don't think I could have
done it earlier than 3839 because I
didn't have the confidence I didn't have
the confidence and I didn't have the
agency when I was in my 20s and and it's
sort of it's sad but it is something
that I've noticed luckily not all women
have to go through that but I have I
have found a lot of other women who who
have felt that they sort of went to us
period in their life for whatever reason
being female in this culture can I think
be a kind of a hard thing yeah thank you
for sharing that way you know that's
good to hear yeah I'm sure that'll be
inspiring for some of those listening
right now you know one thing I want to
touch on as I was I was thinking about
this interview last night I'm like you
know what I want I really wanted to get
into mumblecore you know a lot of people
in the mainstream they're still not
aware of mumblecore how would you define
mumblecore to a general audience well
sadly I'm interesting cuz that term is
just so immediately negative to me and
it just sounds so awful because I think
for a lot of folks like here the mayor
just sort of immediately turned off
because they think it's a bunch of
people mumbling or something which is
totally not the case you know aside from
putting the unfortunate name aside it is
the name with some sort of saddle with
ank so deal with it it doesn't seem to
it represents a community of filmmakers
most of whom are friends of mine who
have not been waiting around to be given
permission to make their films but they
look at the resources at their disposal
and whether it's you know three thousand
dollars and a bunch of funds like Joe
Swanberg in his early 20s when I met him
on the festival circuit was week away
back he was on the festival circuit with
a film called lol and he was really my
first introduction to this kind of
movement or this group of individuals
and he had heard early he had he had
three thousand bucks and over the course
of eight months with his buddies on the
weekends you know they made this film
this really delightful film filled with
incredibly naturalistic performances
like I just never seen anything like it
and I was been fantasizing about having
a very actor centered set and having a
very you know trying to put people at
ease and make it feel almost like a
documentary and here was a version of
that and that
very very inspiring to be close to and
so I'd already been putting together
this recipe where you would start with
people that I wanted to work with as
opposed to writing you know a script
first and then trying to cast from that
script and but the most inspiring thing
about it to me was that DIY aspect that
you could actually just pick up a camera
and go out with friends and and and make
a movie instead of you know waiting for
you know trying to put together a really
commercial project you know a script and
then go into development and and just
wait maybe four years for somebody to
hand you money and you know and give you
permission to make a film it really I
loved the empowering aspect of just
being able to go out and do it but the
other the other things that the
mumblecore sort of humble core
filmmakers are considered to have in
common is that a lot of these films are
being made there's a lot of handheld
camera work a lot of time decisions this
is not for everybody but a lot of them
is sort of one of the country's fix and
proper strokes that you could say is
that a lot of times there's camp held
work that get some feels very cinema
verite you know and it's a little little
dogma style if you think about Dogma in
95 you know is a movement prevalent a
while ago have some of those those
characteristics extremely naturalistic
acting sometimes use of improvisation in
some form or other although some of the
mumblecore filmmakers have scripts that
they stick to what else that's the main
thing DIY very naturalistic and a lot of
times it's about if you're very small
stories or infinite stories you know
stories of people and they're you know
trying to relate to each other
maybe love stories maybe friendships
maybe people and you know sort of
post-collegiate angst - you know
potentially post post-collegiate
my second and third films are about
about people in their in their early 30s
and and and do you think hump day is the
film that's going to bring mumblecore to
the mainstream
well I don't know I don't want to be so
I mean he has definitely been getting a
lot of love from the crust which is I'm
just incredibly grateful for and humbled
by it just opened in New York and you
know where New York and Seattle on
Friday so it's in the midst of its
opening weekend and it will be rolling
out across
I think it's scheduled to open it about
30 cities right now San Francisco and
Berkeley on the 17th and los angeles on
the 24th along with a lot of other ones
you can see the full list of of theatres
and cities it'll be playing in on the
website hump day film.com I think is
what it is pictures which is our
distributor anyway so we'll see we'll
see how much more that it expands beyond
that I mean you know give viewers an
idea our listeners an idea we open in
two theaters on two screens and Bruno
opens and you know 2700 you know we are
we are a tiny film and to say that we're
you know being brought to the mainstream
it's a little a bit of an overstatement
at this point but it's possible and
possible it could be could be the first
mumblecore crossover we'll see I mean
there's another one sort of have
received a lot of love I mean did you
prosper others
marci process half of the due process
others and he is one of my stars one of
the hump day stars and one of the
reasons we bonded was because he is
considered in that in that same canon as
DIY filmmakers and so we had a lot of
mutual friends and when and when we
actually met we found that you know our
filmmaking philosophies were very
similar so his first breakout hit was
off each air when you're also premiered
at Sundance and got a ton of love from
the festival circuit and some press and
also gotta do you know why distribution
and
and Netflix for the second film as well
with a feather Jay called Bankhead also
was picked up by Sony Pictures Classics
you know and it opened West last year
and got broad relief as well so Hyundai
is by far enough oh you know not the
first to forge this betrayal mm-hmm yeah
two great films and I noticed that your
films
hump day and my effortless brilliance
seemed to focus on male friendships you
know which is a subject that I also find
very interesting because I noticed that
men relate with each other differently
than the way women do in their
friendships where like if men feel kind
of threatened of another friend they
kind of almost challenge one another to
a duel you know in basketball or chess
or something whereas women when they it
seems like when they're threatened of
each other they kind of just I don't
know shut off and you know sort of
Stonewall each other what is it about
these stories of male friendships that
kind of draws you to to make movies
about them well again the real you can
trace it back trace back the fact that
those two movies are about men to the
fact that I wanted to start with a
person to work with
and those people happen to be men okay
so that was kind of really how it
happened I mean somebody asked me
recently are you are you just fascinated
by men women I'm really bad by people I
really am you know and it just happened
to be that that I hit a twofer you know
in a row happen to be focused on men but
my first film I started I mean my second
feature my flawless brilliance was the
starting point with Sean Nelson who was
a friend of mine and I just thought
would be a really compelling sort of
center of a film and built the whole
thing out from him and and that film
really has no women I mean there's one
woman it's one tiny scene with a woman
in it but for the most part it's these
guys off in the middle of the woods
without you know then the heiress woman
might be like 200 miles away from them
you know it really is about sort of this
world of these particular guys and how
they relate when they're alone but
I have to say what hump day although the
focus is the two men and in this
relationship that they have an male
friendship I that you know it's just as
much about marriage and the one woman
character in it it's a very strong woman
character I mean actually there's a
couple of minor supporting roles as well
who are women but the the main the key
one is um is Ben's wife the character
played by Mark deep office my new boss
is Ben's wife Anna and she is all those
just can get as much screen time is
absolutely crucial to the films the way
the film works there wouldn't be any
state in that in a story if you didn't
care about her and and she needed to be
just exfoli fleshed out of the guy so I
mean I always feel the need to point
that out but um really is about marriage
and about this particular woman as much
as it is about the guys hmm interesting
mm-hmm now you've completed three
feature films which of the three was the
hardest to make and why challenges and I
probably we go way back the first one
was probably the hardest just because it
was so new while I was on set not only
were we dealing with we had this
wonderful all these resources a
wonderful full crew contingent you know
I don't even know how many people it was
I think it fluctuated between 30 and 50
people on set a day all incredibly
talented hard-working wonderful to be
around
we had a 35-millimeter film camera and
stock and we have you know a nice script
truck and we had all this all this stuff
that we had such little amount of time
we only have 16 days to shoot a feature
which is just not a lot you know when
you're doing it in the traditional way
and I was absorbing so much information
so at the same time that we're working
working working you know so hard and so
fast I was also learning like oh that's
what a gaffer does
this is what a first ad is responsible
for it I mean really was like my it was
like a hardcore film school for me so it
was very intense and but absolutely
exhilarating I remember telling somebody
that it was this period of time feels
like I don't think I've ever been so
stressed out in my entire life and I
don't think I've ever been so happy and
you know it was bad it was just this
incredible combination and it's never
been it's interesting because it's never
been as hard since then and it's but
it's also never been quite that same
crazy manic sheer exhilaration enjoy you
know it's been pretty darn deeply joyous
I mean I I love love love being on set
and I love I really above every aspect
especially with hump day you know I've
always I always edit it all my own work
and how many was the first time I ever
worked with an editor and it was for me
doing my first feature it became all
about seven we Argentine who came all
about collaboration and relationship my
experimental work I've made money off
ten a dozen films or something all by
myself I really did everything maybe had
one key collaborator you know I'd worked
with the DP year I'd work with a
musician or something but really just
one and I would do everything usually by
myself I'd usually shoot and edit an
interview and do sound design I do it
all myself
so I never I know you know ever since we
go way back I know I never want to work
alone again I love love love working
with people who are gonna bring the best
out of me and I'm gonna bring the best
out of them and you know looking for
those special chemical relationships
that you can have with creative
collaborators to make something that's
going to be better than the sum of its
parts right you know just something
that's going to come together in a way
that you you couldn't have made it
happen all by yourself so I'm incredibly
grateful for that and and so yeah it's I
feel like I've built on on that externa
in particular process to kind of key
into that deeper and deeper and deeper
and the last thing I did was Humphrey
what everyone was trying to get around
to mentioning was that NAT Sanders was
invited you know he came in as the
editor and it was the first time I've
ever allowed collaboration in the
editing room which was the Dismas
difficult one I'm a
control freaks so every cell becoming
collaborative has been really difficult
for me and extra exhilarating I think
because I am such a control freak but
it's been so you know I've always had
such a huge payoff the more
collaborative I've become the more the
better the end product it's really been
amazing that's great you were tuned in
the film courage we broadcast live every
Sunday 11 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
here in LA I talk radio calm you can
also find us on itunes search film
courage and subscribe today
Lynn how has it been for you to receive
all the praise and attention you know
when you google your name
you know just pages upon pages pop up
and on you know there's a lot of buzz
surrounding hump day you've been
traveling the festival circuit you've
been giving interviews how is all the
positive attention been for you you know
how does it transformed you well it
truly has been like a Cinderella story I
mean I all the goals that I set out for
this this latest film were exceeded long
ago I mean they were met and they've
been exceeded you know beyond my wildest
dreams I am I've been telling people you
know I'm really glad that my first
feature film didn't get into Sundance
and in there and didn't receive this
kind of you know acclaim just because I
feel so much more ready mentally you
know I didn't know anything back then
and I've learned a lot on the regional
festival circuit and meeting a lot of
other filmmakers meeting programmers
meeting you know getting sort of little
regional audience fan bases here and
there over the over the years with my
last two films and so by the time I
actually got to Sundance for the first
time this this year in January I was so
grateful and so you know not taking
anything for granted you know I don't
know I felt really and I also felt
really like a year ago in March of 2008
I premiered my film we go way back I
mean sorry not we going back to my
effort was brilliant my second feature
film and when I got there I it was it
was the biggest Film Festival I've been
to at the time
I really felt like wow I am totally
failing myself at every point because
there was so much prescient industry
there and I wasn't getting any
interviews I didn't I didn't know how to
do that I didn't have a network I didn't
and so I rely and a lot I realized wow I
really if I get into this festival again
or a bigger one with my next film I
really have to be ready with some you
know I have to have some backup you know
I have to me I need a publicist or a
producer or sales agent or somebody to
really you know help me navigate all of
this so that's what happened with hump
day you know not that long nine months
later or whatever I was Irish I got in
water to Sundance and I knew that I had
to get hit the ground running you know
and I needed to get people in place and
I needed to you know I needed to be
ready technically and so I just felt
more ready and then but what happened
when we got there was just again beyond
a wildest wildest wildest dreams the
fact that we got into narratives the
dramatic competition first of all blew
all of our minds so we thought we would
be in spectrum or another section and
you know we were the only film I think
that did well no that's not sure there
may have been a couple of scene nombre
was sort of one of them too but but one
of the films that you know we haven't
been in the labs we hadn't we didn't
have any name actors we were really we
were really the most truly independent
film in the section and it was just
people really responded well to it the
audiences were full and they laughed and
made love programmers were always very
supportive and it was just but totally
you know a quintessential Sundance
fairytale experience and we have a
Special Jury Prize there and everything
that's happened since then if she's been
overwhelming but getting into Sundance
you know as where the feature really
changes your life I mean I have an agent
and a manager now I never never had one
of those before either of those before
and I'm talking to just really exciting
wonderful producers in New York and LA
it's been very very heavy but I really
tried a really I'm units that's grateful
and happy and you know as I felt like
really the humble the humbling aspect of
it is just as high you know and I think
about all of the other talented
filmmakers but I know who who deserve
the same number of alkaloids you know
and and I know I'm just incredibly
grateful and I'm trying to take it day
by day and really not not you know not I
just want to be as grateful as possible
and when you started out with hump day
deep down you know what were your your
true plans with it I mean were you
making a movie just to make it or did
you kind of wanted to have it take you
somewhere you know where does it get to
kind of beyond the point of making a
movie is not enough and you want to get
to the next level yeah no I mean I
actually from my all my feature films
well I'm not sure you see my second
feature was really an experiment to see
if I could find a way of working that
would be a totally actor centered set
meaning that I would have a set that
would be so stripped-down and so natural
feeling to be there that it would just
put the actors at ease and that I could
get to just pure there be no false notes
you know I was looking for just pure
naturalism again almost to the point
where it feels like a documentary like
it's just the things the conversations
the events are all just unfolding in
front of your eyes naturally and it
doesn't it feels totally unwritten and
that was my that was my big big focus
with that film of my experience was to
see if I could I could get that kind of
you know get some kind of a working
methodology and so the only people
allowed in the room when the shooting is
happening are the camera operators
because there's two people holding
cameras and me if I'm not holding one of
the cameras which I often am and the
sound guy Vinnie and that's it it's just
it's just the barest barest crew and
we're holding cameras one of the reasons
were their handheld and their small is
because I wanted to be you know very
unobtrusive
I didn't allow any lighting instruments
it was very dark style on my philiponius
there was no extra lights allowed and
yeah it was just a very very
naturalistic setting and then the actors
all use their own words so we have an
emotional map for the scene I know what
I want to happen in the scene she's
emotionally but they need to come up
with the words themselves because I know
that the words they're gonna write as
you know a guy in his 30s is gonna be
able to say speak like a guy in the
cities which you know much more so than
if I were to try and write his own words
for so that was my goal with my feelings
and I wanted there to be a film at the
end of it that my main my main go like
plot wasn't as interesting or it wasn't
as important to me I wasn't I wasn't
thinking about those things so much as
how can I get these performances you
know and the fact that I have this
delightful I mean I really love that
film and I love little twists and turns
it takes but my next film I wanted to
really like okay I know I can do this
now you know and so I had a much more
had much more confidence and I'm not
sure sure hand you know in terms of how
to work with the actors but I also
wanted to make I wanted to up my game in
terms of the movie-going experience I
want it to be a little more classic you
know like a little more Hollywood and a
little more like you know sitting down
and you're just gonna be drawn through
this film with a strong narrative Drive
you know the sense of what's gonna
happen next somebody recently described
it to me it's almost like a bank heist
movie because the question is will they
or won't they are they gonna go through
with it or not and we're wandering all
the way up through the end so I did yeah
I did hope to make a film that would
actually be fun to watch and would be
yeah might be you know the crossover
here at the same time for me you know
that I sort of breakout film but for me
the thing is that this film was such a
huge risk I mean the premise is so
absurd the idea that these two straight
guys come up with this art project in
which they make it gay porn together is
such a ridiculous premise and it sounds
so unbelievable you know
we had tried to develop this film in a
classic way where you're looking for
investors you make a business plan and
you're pitching to people I don't think
they ever would have been me it
certainly never would have been made the
way that we were able to make it because
it was such a huge risk you know we were
very skeptical that it would even work
you know but if it didn't work who would
be the wiser you know it's just it was
just me and a bunch of friends in the
hinterlands up in Seattle making this
little film and it would have died a
nice quiet little death and nobody would
have had to know you know no shame so
because that's what's so cool about
making a movie in this way where the
stakes are so low you know that you can
you know you can you can just take the
hugest risk and take the biggest
challenge and the only reason the movie
actually worked was because even though
we were skeptical but we could succeed
we all drove into it completely headlong
you know wholeheartedly fully engaged
and you know if the two guys hadn't had
that level of engagement especially I
mean just never ever ever would have
worked so yeah I can't say enough about
empowering yourself communities but you
want to make you know and going out and
policing yourself because you don't have
to if you don't have anybody to answer
to anybody who's worried about you know
oh how much how commercial is this so
I'm gonna be then I think you can really
make the best movies that you can make
you know absolutely you know I love the
way you're articulating it and and and
discussing it it's you know it's
fantastic then you know when Karen and I
have we have seen hump day and we
laughed out loud draw the entire film
it's a very funny film and and the thing
is while I'm watching it you know you
know I'm kind of bummed out to ask this
question because I thought when I when I
saw the film like all right I have
something that probably no one else is
gonna ask her about the fact that a lot
of the film is shot in close-up and I
guess you have been asked this question
throughout but I'm still curious what
why did you choose as a director to say
you know what I'm gonna shoot a lot of
this in close-up will some of the
reasoning behind that
well the main reason is I'm you know on
the love with the human face and so it's
kind of a dead giveaway looking you know
right at what would I prefer to look at
you know I guess I'm a little like Peter
we're in that way I remember when I was
in my you know in my youth looking at
watching Picnic at Hanging Rock and even
the year of living dangerously he's
Peter Weir of film so he's just nobody
does a close-up witness even you know
nobody that's a close-up like Peter Weir
and you're just staring at these
people's faces I was always just like in
love with those that aspect of his films
because I felt so close to these
characters and I felt like I was really
mining the depths that their souls you
know and I loved but he didn't shy away
from from that from the human face oh I
think we have a lot in common in that
way I this you know my films especially
how hump day is really about the nuances
of human interaction between husband and
wife between two mouths really really
you know now friends who really want to
connect but but you know it's kind of a
love-hate relationship really you know
there's so much going on and there's so
much going on under the surface of the
words so you've got the their their
dialog and then you've got you know the
looks on their faces and reactions and
little nuances what's going on behind
their eyes and I just didn't want the
audience to miss any of that you know I
mean that's really where the drama is
taking place it's in their faces to me
so that's why it's so it's so close up
it was funny because in you know I was
just in Chicago for a preview screening
about I don't know a week ago or so and
I was in i sat on the biggest screen
I've seen it on so far and it was one of
those theaters was kind of a newer
multiplex it was a very raked speak
audience set up and it was really
comfortable comfortable chairs but you
were really close to this gigantic
screen you know I was like I think
somebody's probably gonna ask me about
this because it looks like you could
just you know crawl up into a doorknob
Wow crazy how big it looks on a huge
screen but um ya know I'm I was I'm
really glad I shot it that way Lin I
wish we could discontinue with this
conversation on and on and on we're
gonna we're gonna have to boil it down
to this the last couple questions here
now hump day was one of the last I mean
you know as you mentioned hump day was
one of the true independent films at
Sundance you know and beyond that it was
one of the few films this year to walk
away with distribution from standing
sundaes so in that vein it is a film
that gives a lot of filmic independent
filmmakers like myself hope that you
know that there's a chance for me is
that something that crosses your mind do
you say to yourself like wow I'm
inspiring other filmmakers out there
well you know I'm that wouldn't that
makes me really happy whenever somebody
says that to me and I I do I get I get
messages about that quite often folks
saying you you know this story is a
really inspiring one in it I'm really
really glad you know we were we were
totally ready I was completely ready to
self distribute if necessary to do
whatever it took to get this film out
and there are luckily ways to do that
you know I mean the distribution for
independent films in particular is
pretty distribution a prospect's you
know for distribution traditional
distribution companies you know they're
getting their own narrow narrower and
narrower those those outlets and those
companies looking for films and it's
really it can be really disheartening
but luckily there are it seems like
they're also raised you know there's
more kind of it is possible to get your
film out there yourself as well you know
there are more ways than one you're not
completely dependent on those companies
but again you know I don't know if this
is the last film I'll ever make bit more
like I know it's not the lesson will
ever make but the last film I ever makes
it you know first unless no make that
gets bought by the distributor I have no
idea what's what's in store you know for
the industry or for myself so again I'm
not taking anything for granted but I am
very happy to be here when anybody says
that they're inspired by
this story it's great feeling because I
think anybody who wants to make a film
should go out and pick up the camera and
make a film and lastly let's just touch
upon because it isn't it's starting the
roll out in theaters now it's in New
York City this weekend it's in Seattle
this weekend how how is it doing thus
far and its theatrical run and it's
pretty darn well yeah it's it's really
exciting it's showing at the Angelika
theater Film Center and in New York
which is when I was in New York was my
favorite theater went there all the time
and so I was just in New York and I'm
taking pictures of the coming soon
you know my movie poster in the coming
soon and just thrilled beyond belief to
see it you know I'd seen a trailer show
before moving down there I miss them
it's very surreal for me and it's
showing in my favorite childhood theater
that I had when I was growing up and in
Seattle the holodeck sit here and yeah
I've been doing q and A's and the
audience's are loving it and we were
sold out got a standing ovation on
Friday night was very very joyous and
wonderful here and supposedly Angelica
the reports on getting in New York is
that it's also doing well that's well
there so I don't know what the figures
are yet but it's looking looking pretty
good congratulations and we're just so
happy for you and so excited thank you
you know we hope they get John and we
you know once again down the line and
here you know with what you're up to
we've been speaking with filmmaker and
Lynne Shelton Lynne once again thank you
thank you you know thank you for joining
us
Karen I guess is where I turn over to
you okay well our quote of the week
comes from yet another talented female
filmmaker Nora Ephron Efron's films
Silkwood When Harry Met Sally Sleepless
in Seattle heartburn and many other
titles delve deep into the problems that
plagued relationships infidelity trust
and weather men and women can really
just be friends everyone makes a
statement about romantic relationships
and movies referring to couples on the
big screen she says it struck me that
the movies had spent more than half a
century saying they lived happily ever
after
and the following quarter century
warning that they'll be lucky to make it
through weekend possibly now we're
entering a third era in which the movies
will be sounding a note of cautious
optimism you know it just might work
what other type of movie you're making
whether it be romantic comedy sci-fi or
adult fantasy Dave and I hope your
ending finds your audience better than
before they walked into the theater or
started the DVD player have a great week